foreign
my name is Shawna Tay jellenberg I use
she her pronouns
um I am the director of the office for
student access
um and I'm presenting today with Emily
um Hill House
and I'll introduce her as well uh she is
the director of student academic Support
Services
um and we're here just to kind of talk
about the resources we provide
um and how we we can assist and support
your learning while here at OHSU
okay so today we'll discuss uh student
academic Support Services
um the office for student access and
then how can we help you all what
questions do you have
um really this is a time to kind of
engage with us a bit more and and get
your questions answered
um hopefully a little bit faster than
trying to play email tag or phone tag
with us
okay so
um just really quickly I have laryngitis
so if my voice cuts out I apologize so
um but
um as
shaunity said I'm Emily Hillhouse
director of student academic support
services and at its core what student
academic Support Services provides is
guidance for helping students learn more
effectively and efficiently so like
breaking that down a little bit we talk
about study skills motivation and goal
setting memorization strategies test
taking skills test anxiety time
management it's really
um a resource that helps every learner
figure out where they're struggling and
why and then guides them through the
many different strategies that are
available to them
next slide
so common things we have students coming
to us saying are things like I'm
studying really hard but I can't
remember anything or there's just too
much information or I don't have time to
do everything usually students will come
to us feeling
very overwhelmed by everything and so I
think that a really important part of
um if you were thinking of reaching out
for our services or if you're supporting
somebody else who's thinking of reaching
out for our services is to understand
that
you don't have to know why you're
struggling or what kind of solution
you're looking for before you come to us
you don't need to come to me saying
um please give me a planner I need to
know how to use a planner it can it can
be you can just come and go ah and then
we will figure it out from there and
that's totally fine
um next slide
and I think a really important thing or
in terms of how we frame academic
Support Services is helping Learners
understand where they have power in
their situation why this is important is
because we tend to
feel like education is something that is
happening to us it feels like we are
like just swept along like it's like
people are teaching us things and it
feels very passive and the more we feel
passive about our education the worse it
feels it feels very stressful to
constantly be reacting to things that
are happening to us
and so a lot of what we're doing is
helping students move from a place where
they are just reacting just being like
I have to do this oh no wait now you're
telling me I have to do this and you
know like going from that very reactive
place to a place where they are taking
control over their learning
understanding what aspects of their
learning are things that they can choose
so that they what they can choose to do
about each situation so in order to sort
of get into this a little bit we're
going to do a little activity so if we
go to the next slide
um we're gonna be talking about the
difference between
approaching education in a passive
reactive way to thinking about how you
can think can look at education from an
active active
acting way sorry my brain is also not
100 yet so
um so what I want you to do is if we go
to the next slide and if any of you have
been to any of my workshops before you
may have run into this activity
previously but what I want you to do is
to just take a minute to read this
passage
okay
so in the chat I'd like you to put
how did that make you feel
how did you feel reading that that
Passage
entirely confused
yeah very confused it feels confusing a
lot of people find it quite stressful
well
discombobulated
I was at the I was thinking about going
to the beach
laughs
okay so if we could go to the next slide
what I'd like you to try to do
is go ahead yeah it makes you feel kind
of dumb right what I want you to do is
go ahead and in the chat
write down everything that you remember
don't hit enter until I say go but go
ahead and just dump everything you
remember into the chat box and when I
say go hit enter but not yet so right
now just type what you know what you
remember into the chat box
okay hit enter
foreign
[Laughter]
wait a second
you don't remember a lot more
than I ever do
um so let's go ahead to the next slide
so
what if I tell you that we remember more
and we understand things better and we
generally feel better about our studying
if before you go if instead of
approaching any reading or any lecture
passively if beforehand you have some
context for it in this case it would be
figuring out generally what it's about
and generally how the information is
structured so if we go to the next slide
this reading was generally about kites
and how the information is structured is
making kites flying kites and possible
complications for flying kites so what I
wanted you to do is go ahead and read
the text one more time with this in mind
that it's about
flying kites and then it's organized
with making kites flying kites and
things that can go wrong and see how
that changes your experience of reading
the text so next slide
laughs
yeah
does that feel how does that feel this
time
does it feel better
right right exactly so let's go to the
next slide
let's do it one more time see if you
remember a little bit more this time so
again put it into the chat box and then
don't hit enter until I say go
yes that is absolutely part of it or
another way to think of it is that in
terms of memory connections are really
really powerful
okay hit enter
you're like no but we didn't want to do
it this time
so
part of me
so did it feel like you understood it
and remembered it better this time
exactly
and so what what you just experienced is
if we can go to the next slide
is the difference between approaching a
text a text passively versus actively I
could go into a lot of details this
isn't actually a presentation about
learning strategies but this is a
learning strategy that we call
previewing which is exactly about
creating a framework or context for
information before you receive it so
that you're able to more actively engage
with the context as you receive it sorry
with the content as you receive it and
all that this is the kind of why I'm
talking about it today is that
this is
kind of stuff that we do as learning
Specialists is help you understand that
your learning doesn't that when you
approach learning very passively
emotionally it makes you feel worse
whereas when you are active there are
many things that you can do to increase
how you're actively engaging with the
material which will emotionally feel
better but will also help you learn
things much more effectively and that's
what we're here to help with so if we
can go to the next slide
this gets to the the base philosophy of
what we do which is that your learning
is within your control and this is a
really really important thing to start
with because this is generally not how
we think about learning we tend to think
about learning as
something that we are born with as in it
is like a character trait like I am a a
good student or a bad student I'm a fast
reader or a slow reader or I'm good or
bad at taking standardized tests these
are all narratives that we tell
ourselves and it becomes intertwined
with our ego which is really really
problematic because what it means is
that as you're going through your
academic career here if you hit a
stumbling block if something becomes
hard for you or if you're not getting
the results that you want it becomes
evidence to support this narrative so
that if you struggle with something it's
I am bad at this thing it's because I Am
Naturally this is something I'm just bad
at and when you think of it that way
there's not much you can do about it
because it's just who you are naturally
you were born that way
and this isn't actually true about
learning learning is actually a
collection of skills and strategies that
you have developed over the course of
your academic career starting from when
you were five years old and so it feels
super natural and like part of who you
are because you started so early but
it's actually something that you have
developed over the course of your
academic career by crowdsourcing by
watching your peers and your instructors
and just like any crowdsourcing it's
only as good as the crowd you are
sourcing from which means that you may
have come into this program with all of
the skills that you need to be
successful but if you haven't that isn't
a moral failing it isn't it isn't a
problem it's actually just something
that you can reach out for support for
and that's why we exist here at OHSU is
because
moving into the programs that we have
here is usually materially different
from what people have experienced before
and so many people will have come here
without the specific skills they need
for the environment that they are now in
and
we're here to support you with that and
um so
if you can go to the next slide
specifically what we help you do is help
you understand
first first of all help you identify
what you want to learn and then how you
were going to learn it figure out what
strategies you were going to use and
then we also help a lot with like when
you are going to learn it in terms of
like creating a schedule creating
structure so that you are getting things
done because depending on your program
some programs are highly structured and
so it's more a figuring uh it's more a
case of figuring out how to fit yours
your learning needs within a very busy
work or research schedule or it's you
have so much time and then it's then
time just sort of slips away and so you
need to have more structure so you
actually get things done so we work as
it says on the slide we work with
students to help you find personalized
concrete realistic and specific
strategies
and I think a really important part of
this is this whole idea of what we do is
to understand that there isn't a right
way to do this there isn't like you're
not going to come and talk to me or to
my co-worker Annie Nicholson who's the
other learning specialist here you're
not going to come to us and have us say
oh you're doing it all wrong this is
what you ought to be doing it doesn't
work like that it's about figuring out
what works for you personally which
means that you may see some of your
colleagues and peers using strategies
that you've tried before and they don't
work for you and this isn't and they're
working well really well for them and so
this isn't like oh you ought to be doing
that like if a strategy doesn't work for
you don't do it do I do something that
does work for you
um and so it's very much working with us
is very much helping you figure out what
of the many many strategies could work
for you personally
so if we go to the next slide
um
how we support Learners are we do a
combination of one-on-one appointments
and workshops like we have what you know
sort of like what I'm doing right now we
so one-on-one appointments is you come
and meet with us and we figure out
what's going on for you personally
um in terms of major workshops if your
group wants to request them we do one
about test taking strategies and test
preparation we do one that is more about
like time management Focus
um and getting the most out of lecture
so we would talk in depth about that
previewing strategy that that kind
exercise was talking about
um we also do workshops on
um
um reading group work exam anxiety NCLEX
is specifically the nursing
certification exam but if you have
certification exams or board exams you
have to pass then we help with those as
well
um the next slide
if you do want to reach out to us for
support you can reach out to us at
learningsupport ohsu.edu
um and that's it for me if should we
hold questions to the end Shantae or do
should we have a pause here for
questions but we can pause here for
questions then they don't have to hold
um The Learning support questions all
the way through
so that's good so does anybody have any
questions for me
are these like holiday hands like
they're like wearing green gloves
it's really cute
that is an excellent question yes we do
I think I lost connectivity there for a
second
um I can really quickly show you all how
to find the um the information on Sakai
I'm going to steal sharing from you
really quickly
there are red gloves too
okay can you all see this okay
so if you log into Sakai
then
um
you're I mean your welcome page looks
like this up at the top will be your
classes any coursework that you're
involved in
if you click this red button student
academic Support Services
but takes you to our Sakai site and the
first page just explains how to make an
appointment with us so if you forget the
email address you can always come here
to find it again but over here on the
left hand side we have sort of self we
have self-service learning support tools
so if you wanted to learn more about
reading strategies for example you click
it and it takes you through some of our
major strategies relating to reading
strategies
um and then we have you know because I
am taking memory techniques all sorts of
things
um and we also have downloadable
planners and whatnot so you're totally
welcome to explore this anytime you want
um let me see if I can
oh yes of course please share
information and if if any of if if
anybody wants um to have I'm sure Shawna
Tay has this as well but we have
advertising slides that can be included
in PowerPoint presentations as well
um so if that is something that you
wanted to include that way then you
could reach out to us and we can share
those with you
all right well I'm handing it over to
you today thank you all so much
awesome well so I work in the office for
student access so we are the office that
provides academic accommodations for
Disabilities and I like to emphasize
it's not only for permanent disabilities
but temporary
um I think that sometimes doesn't always
um get communicated so not that we want
any of our students to have accidents or
anything but if you you know get a
concussion or
um you know sprain an ankle or you know
break a bone we can help with those
temporary accommodations as well so
definitely know there's there's supports
for that
um in terms of like what what is a
disability
um I think a lot of times
um I'll have students ask for like a
list of all the disability diagnoses we
accommodate but what we actually do is
we use the Ada definition of disability
which is
um a physical or mental impairment that
substantially limits one or more major
life activities
um so that is a very very broad
definition
um and some major life activities can
include caring for oneself seeing
hearing eating sleeping walking standing
lifting learning reading concentrating
thinking it is really there's a
never-ending list of what major life
activities might be so I think it's
really important to understand if you're
experiencing a barrier
um due to like a diagnosis please reach
out to us that we likely are able to
come up with some accommodation to a
assessed
in terms of like what are reasonable
accommodations
um often we talk about there are
barriers in environments I really like
this illustration
um because there are barriers in lots of
areas they could be a physical barrier
it could be maybe how you learn if you
have like a learning disability or ADHD
um because we Academia is structured in
a very specific way
usually for specific types of Learners
and so there can be barriers to that so
what accommodations do is kind of level
the playing field so by like reducing
the impact of those barriers so that
middle image there I think one thing
we're seeing more is more Universal
Design for Learning being Incorporated
so this idea that all Learners of all
abilities would be able to participate
in their academics without even needing
an accommodation because it's all
already built to be accessible so right
now because we're not quite to the
overall Universal Design our office is
here to help with that with those
accommodations to to help reduce those
barriers
a big thing is I like to talk a lot
about what accommodations are and are
not because I think there can a lot of
times be some stigma around requesting
accommodations and the idea that it's
it's kind of special treatment which
accommodations are not
um they are there to level the playing
field
um they're there to mitigate any impacts
of symptoms they don't lower academic
standards they don't
um they don't get rid of requirements
they're just there to kind of help
bridge the gap between the way you learn
and how your like course your program is
structured
um so a big thing is it's not special
treatment if you have a disability it is
your legal right to accommodation so I
always want students to be aware that
you do have rights and protections and
we want to make sure that you assert
those
foreign
accommodations
um I think are most common is testing
accommodations and that usually includes
like extended testing time ability to
test in an environment with fewer
distractions fewer noises
some students might find it's more
helpful
um if they can use like technology to
dictate
um exam answers so we can help with
technology needs so there's really all
sorts of testing accommodations
assistive technology is another one so
this can be I find we work a lot with
Emily's office in helping students
understand like what their learning
style is so if you're more of an
auditory learner versus a visual learner
sometimes being able to listen to your
textbooks can be really really helpful
and that's something our office can help
with
um if you need materials in different
formats or schedule modifications or
Urban ergonomic Furniture really we
provide accommodations in all areas
related to your academic program so if
you have required internships or
practicums anything like that again we
we assist with that this is definitely
not an exhaustive list of accommodations
we
um basically we meet with students and
figure out what those barriers are and
there are times we create accommodations
because it's a new situation
um and so we're really here to kind of
brainstorm with you what Solutions might
be possible
in terms of the accommodation process it
is an interactive process
um so the big thing I always tell
students is they you don't just show up
and say Here's my documentation I have
ADHD
tell me what accommodations I'm eligible
for it is a a customized process
um one student with ADHD may need one
set of accommodations whereas another
student may need a completely different
set it's very much customized to your
specific learning needs and your
specific like barriers that you're
experiencing so it is an interactive
process
you would meet with us and we would
determine what accommodations you're
eligible for and then you'll get an
accommodation letter and I think the big
thing I always want students to know
that accommodation letter doesn't list
any disability diagnosis information
doesn't list any symptom information
just list what your accommodation
eligibilities are so we are really
really
um
we find the confidentiality is a big big
thing especially in Health Sciences
um there's still again a lot of stigma
around requesting accommodations
um And discussing disability and so we
really want any disclosures outside of
our office to be on your terms
um so we want to give you as much
autonomy with that as possible
and then you would request your
accommodations and work with what we
call a pal or a program accommodation
liaison so you have somebody within your
program who is there to help make sure
you get your accommodation so again
we're not going to leave you without
support once you get that letter we're
still here to support you as well
um the big thing I always want students
to know as well is we can always update
accommodations so we know symptoms can
change and just learning environments
change as you get into new
um new rotations or new classes or new
um learning experiences your
accommodation needs might change so we
can always update things and I
definitely want you to reach out and let
us know if different accommodations are
needed
and then in terms of confidentiality
um we do in terms of disability
documentation that is kept within our
office we maintain our own database
um and so your registration with our
office doesn't become part of your
student record so future schools future
employers won't know you received
accommodations while at OHSU unless you
tell them so again we definitely value
your confidentiality and want to make
sure that you understand what
information is being shared and with
whom we would also only share that
you're even eligible for accommodations
with people who are part of making sure
you get those accommodations
um so it's not like anyone at OHSU can
just call us up and say hey we want a
list of every student registered with
your office unless they have an academic
need to know they we do a lot of I can
either confirm nor deny that student
that student has connected with us so
definitely again know we're protecting
your confidentiality as much as possible
and then I also like to highlight there
are additional ways we support students
Beyond accommodations
accommodations tend to be very
individualized and usually reactive a
barrier has presented a student receives
a new diagnosis
um you know and then we kind of react to
that barrier but there are proactive
things we can do as well so we do
trainings on anti-ablism and disability
inclusion we do trainings on Universal
Design so kind of that more proactive
building accessible
environments but we also do a
exploration of assistive technology I am
a big fan of Technology because that is
something you can take with you so if
you find something as hopeful to your
learning it might be helpful in your
workplace as well and technology is
often something that translates pretty
easily from an academic environment to a
workplace environment so if you're ever
interested in exploring that like
definitely let us know we also assist
with applying for accommodations for
National exams so if you have
certification board exam licensure exams
things like that while our office
wouldn't be able to approve because the
exam is outside of OHSU we can help you
with that process it can definitely be
overwhelming sometimes trying to figure
out all the ins and outs of requesting
those and we're here to help with that
as well
and then for more information about
accommodations links to our appointment
request form documentation guidelines
applications
um our main site is ohsu.edu student
Dash access
um and that also has additional
resources on there as well so we have
links to National groups for Health
Sciences students with disabilities we
have resources to additional
um learning resources disability
resources faculty trainings all sorts of
things there and if you ever have
anything that you come across that you
think would be helpful to add definitely
reach out to us the other thing in terms
of our appointment request form if
you're unsure if you might qualify or if
you're kind of unsure if you even want
to register we do
um confidential consultations with
students as well so that would be one
way just to kind of get an idea if it
might be helpful without kind of
starting the official registration
process so definitely reach out to us to
find out more
and then we can also be reached at
reached at student access at ohsu.edu
cheers anybody have any questions about
accommodations or accessibility
anything like that
Shanta Tay this is Andrea
um I have a question so if a student has
an accommodation
is it their responsibility to let their
instructor know of the accommodation
because how does it how does somebody
who's teaching the course know yeah so
it is within
um within this specific program it is
each program kind of has their own
um own process but within The Graduate
Studies
programs it is up to the student to
basically pass on their accommodation
letter
um the big thing is it's also up to
students to decide if they want to use
their accommodations or not
um so especially I find most often like
students with testing accommodations
they get into a course where they don't
have exams they might not forward on
their letter so again we just want as
much autonomy for students as possible
School in deciding who they even let
know that they have accommodations
because letting people know you have
accommodations also is identifying as
having a disability so again we want to
give as much
um much autonomy as possible in choosing
to disclose or not but also we do let
students know there often is a little
bit of lead time to coordinate
accommodations so making sure that they
are giving enough notice to instructors
to their program if they need need
accommodations as well so accommodations
aren't retroactive
once that letter is sent out then
they're active but if like a deadline or
a test has passed before they send out
the letter it wouldn't apply to that
previous side of things
okay so then it is the student
responsibility to let the instructor
know do they should they let them know
prior to the course beginning if they
have the letter before then or as the
course begins is that still sufficient
so it depends on how programs are
coordinated
um in general I let students know if
they can let their faculty know as soon
as they have contact info that gives way
more lead time more ability to
coordinate things I think the longest
lead time we have is for like testing we
usually recommend at least 10 business
days
um so again depending on how quickly
exams are it can be helpful to do prior
to the term starting but we also do
students register throughout the term
way of rolling rolling registration
um so a student again might not might
have an accident might have
um just gotten diagnosed and so letters
could be issued midterm as well okay
and then it was interesting I think I
heard you say they are not retroactive
so if say they go through a test and it
doesn't work out for them then they
can't present their letter and say hey I
need accommodations yeah they can going
forward but it wouldn't mean they can
retake the test with okay time or
accommodations yeah thank you that was
helpful
okay well definitely always feel free to
reach out I think the biggest thing we
are here as a resource for both students
and faculty and staff so if you ever
have questions for those of you who are
faculty or staff and are like how do I
how do I do this or how do I make things
more accessible definitely reach out to
us we are we are here as an
accessibility resource across campus for
all members
we appreciate you coming in and
providing the information for the
students and faculty it's been very
helpful
thanks for having us
we'll do it again I'm sure
feel better Emily